how excited are you to be playing this
event here in Africa I'm happy that for
the first time in history they're
hosting such a powerful tournament here
in Africa I think it's the first for me
but it's first for basically everyone I
think it's pretty exciting for us it's
pretty exciting I hope for for the
locals and I hope it will be a great
success first of all a big football fan
and they've had a lot of good
footballers over the years so it's
that's one of the reasons why I thought
it was exciting to come here and also
yeah just to visit a completely new part
of the world for for me was was huge and
I mean I could could apply them in Paris
again but I thought this is way more
more exciting well I'm actually really
happy because back when last time I was
in st. Louis when I played linear Yassir
by accident he just has beef if you ever
get a wild-card for for the this
initiative Grantchester which place
would you prefer to go and immediately I
said I would prefer cote d'ivoire it's
my first time in Africa and people here
are really friendly they always smells
to you when they give you some help and
also the city reminds me of my hometown
and certainly it's good to see an event
being held here in Africa and I'll be
John and just seeing all the local
players having a chance to come and see
the top the elite of the chess world
compete in a major event and sort of get
an idea of what it's really like at the
top so I think in general it's a good
way of trying to on further chess here
in Africa and I think for all the locals
it's an opportunity that they have never
had before so I think it's very very
good for the chest culture locally the
CTF it's beautiful
oh well it's probably the strongest the
chess tournament which has had been
played in Africa so I'm very excited to
be here to play here and actually as a
moment I like the organization very much
the hotel's very nice and the food is
just brilliant
I mean I'm just really glad that but
that more people can you know can follow
chess and can be involved into the
process of us that's just great
of course it's it's it's great for my
continent for Africa to to have such a
big tournament here organizing the
the last few years been many steps
trying to improve just in Africa
bringing some organizing some
international tournaments but nothing
close to this level of course I'm hoping
that the people of the country bar will
be will be inspired by the games and I
will try and do my best to provide that
you